[موسيقى]
يتجه هؤلاء المحاربون البيئيون إلى
معركة غير عادية
[موسيقى
] العدو ، وهو نوع خطير وغازٍ يدمر
الموائل المحلية ، تسبب في مشكلة كبيرة جدًا
هنا في مياه المحيط الأطلسي الغربية ،
مما أدى إلى اندلاع الهجوم وهو أليكس فوغ
عالم أحياء بحرية و  ناشط الحفاظ على البيئة
لشاطئ دستين فورت والتون في فلوريدا
بانهاندل ، يُعرف باسم فتى
أسد البحر حول هذه الأجزاء ، إن سمكة الأسد
شغوف بما أفعله في حياتي اليومية
[الموسيقى]
سمك الأسد موطنه الأصلي في جنوب المحيط الهادئ
والمحيط الهندي سيتم اكتشافه لأول مرة
على طول  ساحل فلوريدا في
منتصف الثمانينيات من القرن الماضي على بعد أكثر من عشرة آلاف ميل
من المنزل ، هناك الكثير من النظريات
حول كيفية ظهورها بالضبط ولكن
الخيار الأكثر ترجيحًا هو أن
أسماك الأسد كانت في تجارة الأحواض المائية
وانتهى الأمر بإطلاقها من قبل صاحب الحيوانات الأليفة
على مدى  سنوات تضاعف عدد السكان
وتسبب في الخراب إذا
وضعت شيئًا ما في النظام البيئي
ليس من المفترض أن يكون هناك وكانوا
يأكلون نفس الطعام مثل ذلك  أنا من
سلالاتك الأصلية ، هناك منافسة
هناك حيث يوجد رعاة مثل
سمكة الببغاء الخاصة بك إذا كانت أسماك الأسد تصلي على
سمكة الببغاء ، لم تعد تلك الأسماك الببغاء
تحافظ على الشعاب المرجانية نظيفة وفي كثير
من الأحيان يمكن للطحالب أن تتفوق على الشعاب
المرجانية وتتسبب في موت مجموعة من الشعاب المرجانية.
لا يوجد لدى أسماك الأسد الأسوأ مفترسات في هذه
المياه الغربية ، فهي تنحصر في
شيء آخر إلى جانب الحيوانات المفترسة لتولي
المسؤولية والحفاظ على هذه الأسماك تحت
السيطرة وهذا نحن غواصون ، حسنًا ، نحن في وضع
محايد ،
قد يكون هناك صيادون
لم يكونوا أبدًا يعتبرون أنفسهم حقًا.
دعاة الحفاظ على البيئة ولكن هذا
شيء يمكنهم الذهاب إليه للغوص ،
يمكنهم الذهاب لحصاد سمكة ومساعدة
النظام البيئي في العملية
التي يجب عليهم توخي الحذر على الرغم من أن تلك
الأشواك على طول
ظهورهم وجوانبهم سامة لن تموت
ولكن يمكنك ذلك  قد يذرف دمعة أو اثنتين
للحفاظ على سلامة أيديهم ، يستخدم الغواصون
رمحًا طويلًا لصيد سمكة الأسد ، وأداة
غريبة تسمى حارس حديقة الحيوان
لاحتوائها  إنها عبارة عن
أنبوب بلاستيكي من نوع apa يسمح لك بوضع
سمكة الأسد فيه ويمنع
الأشواك من الاختناق وربما اللسع
الذي تريده ، فأنت تريد التأكد من أنك
لن تتعرض
للدغة من الأخبار السارة أن سمكة الأسد تتذوق طعمًا
جيدًا ولديها  أصبح نوعًا من
الأطعمة الشهية في المطاعم الفخمة على
طول الساحل
مثل زعانف gw في نيو أورلينز حيث
أصبحت هذه قصة إيتون للتغلب عليه
عندما سمعنا عن سمكة الأسد التي
بدأت في فعل النظام البيئي هنا
نريد أن نفعل كل ما في وسعنا لك  تعرف على
المساعدة في حل المشكلة وحصلنا على
أول شحنة من أسماك الأسد ، لقد
فوجئنا في الواقع بسرور
لأنواع غازية ، ربما تكون واحدة
من أكثر الأنواع اللذيذة التي تذوقتها على الإطلاق
، ويعمل المطعم مباشرة مع
صيادي الرمح الذين يزودون
سمكة الأسد الخاصة بهم.  تجارية
وجيدة للبيئة بشكل حاسم
تتجنب أساليبهم الصيد العرضي وتستهدف
العدو عندما تدير شبكة عبر
المياه التي لا تعرفها أبدًا على وجه الدقة  ما
تقوم به عندما يتعلق الأمر بصيادي الرمح هؤلاء ،
فهم لا يحصدون سوى
الأسماك التي نبحث عنها بالضبط
ولا يوجد شيء آخر نحصل عليه على الأرجح هو
الشيء الأكثر أهمية الذي نقوم به
للتأكد من أننا نعرف من ومتى وأين وكيف
أوليفر  تم القبض على الأسماك وهي
تفهم سبب أهميتها أيضًا إذا
خرجت أعداد أسماك الأسد عن
السيطرة ، فيمكن أن تأكل العديد من الأنواع التي
اعتاد المطعم على وجودها في قائمتها ،
وهي الطريقة الوحيدة لتحفيز
الناس على الخروج هناك والقضاء
عليها وصيد أكبر عدد ممكن.  بقدر ما يمكنهم
هو خلق طلب في شكل سوق
ثم ازدهار تعلم أنه سيكون لديك الكثير
من الأشخاص الذين يبحثون عن
سمكة الأسد ، والهدف هو التحكم في
تعداد سمكة الأسد
وليس القضاء عليها ، لذا ستكون سمكة الأسد موجودة
دائمًا هنا.
حيث سيجدون مكانهم في ذلك
النظام البيئي وفي شبكة الطعام
[الموسيقى]